about a gender nah example men tend to
be better in leadership I mean
stereotypes are there for a reason and
they come from somewhere you know but
overall we are generalizing and I feel
like there's a lot of like we've been
bashing right now with in the workplace
but if we look at it as well you know
in history the women went to work what
sort of from the 50s and 60s and whereas
we first had you know the women being
the homeowner
Homemaker that's the word I'm looking
for work on like the farm too yeah sorry
I'm thinking you awesome actually I was
thinking about the us too that's where I
read the statistics from but basically
when the women went into the workforce
sort of the family side of things
struggled that was also when divorce
rates went up by I think like 80 or
something crazy like that but it was
also after the development of birth
control yes it all came around the same
same time yeah but I mean um they're
like bring me back to the streets
I think we're gonna be that
particular like men are better than
leaders oh where is this world going I
can't say nothing God just no think out
loud at this point no wait so you're
saying we should be able to say that
we keep saying there are exceptions and
I'm like I know there are exceptions but
like we can make General statements
about it to be there though I do think
it depends on the topic with
generalization like the topics that we
had before that were very like it could
be very yeah touch like touchy in
subjects it generalizing can be too much
like when you were both going talking
about like the specifics of the numbers
you were using it can be dependent on
the topic really say generalization we
all do it with everything but yeah with
certain like subjects you have to be a
bit more particular I think I think
nowadays
um
with the rise
and evolution of feminism
um more women
um who here
um certain generalizations that don't
necessarily paint
um women in a good light will take
umbrage to those generalizations and
then those will be that they will be the
ones to say something you know get
triggered and want to kind of dispute it
or even if even if it's a factual thing
um though they will still say I don't
agree yeah fudge the numbers uh so
statistically there are more men in the
workforce therefore the statistics will
lean better into their that favor so in
order to say that men are better leaders
numerically they are better leaders
no because they asked women the the
study I was saying was um they they
picked female lead Industries and
they're like with the female-led
industry I can I can I can read it you
have to be very careful pearly things
what about statistics
guys watch it guys Who's laughing in the
mic it's me I'm sorry I'm sorry I
apologize what should we go off our
feelings so if we don't go off of stats
what are we going to go off of but I can
like who wrote These statistics who
funded these statistics thank you the
let's see
a new study UCLA okay
yeah I know the I know the University
thank you yeah it says I've taught at
UCLA
um
a much smaller survey by UCLA Law Firm
staff UCLA yeah them it's a college
American so it's not UCL no they they
took stats from the UK too I think no no
this is American oh it's American yeah I
think interesting I think what she's
trying to say thank you um is just how
many people
would actually fill out stuff to do with
this and then those demographical people
I don't care for what I'm actually
saying just trying to reference what
you're saying so those people that would
fill out a survey versus people that
wouldn't feel like surfing
this is juice it's just I just feel like
sometimes we jump through hoops whenever
women like I just feel like sometimes I
feel like we we jump through hoops
whenever women look bad like to to
somehow change the narrative for us not
to look bad but we can say women run the
world and nobody nobody even pushes back
on that
so it's like you have to understand we
can always so
with Statistics okay so men line numbers
don't men like women like numbers don't
lie but numbers can be manipulated
depending on who's looking at them and
what they wanted to say so we can say
that right but if we look generally how
the world since the beginning of time
has done censuses then we we we take the
majority or we take it we take a slice
of it and then we we generalize right if
we don't do that we will never ever able
to come to some type of like general you
know decision on something so we have to
do that it might not be perfect
Sometimes some people might get roped
into it some people might get left out
but this is the best that we have and
this is what and this is what the world
has been using since the beginning of
time from when from when Pontius Pilate
had to go do sentences and go literally
from then them times there from when the
Passover was happening and they wanted
to know how many people were inside each
from them times they'd be taking numbers
down here so unless one of you guys can
give me I was gonna say I can give me
one night because because you're
speaking about before the dawn of time
before the dawn of time it was a man's
man's world that's the saying that I
love you people like to bring up here
from back in the day like it's a man's
world maybe it's very man-made because
men built the world yeah but for me it's
like condition of the Mind see it from
my perspective I did psychology so I
believe that everything is like some
form of like introductory is that
planting a seed is going to grow if I'm
always surrounded by male counterparts
in power if I'm always being told that a
male is the one that's meant to hold me
down you know protect me like Amel is
meant to be you know my version of God
essentially because he's meant to be my
everything at this point this is the
society that they built up on we've
created the women couldn't do it yeah
there's no society that we couldn't we
wasn't given a chance no we were that we
could have done just like the men did it
but like no but wait wait but no but no
Society wait wait wait wait stop do not
interrupt me no no society that has
stood the test of time was run by women
women had just as much opportunity as
men
and men and men still run the world I
mean they run our whole infrastructure
if if men disappeared tomorrow like the
lights would go out the plumbing would
stop women they would be fine but it's
possible to to an extent but the point
that kind of make is that imagine if
you're only being surrounded by a male
energy you're not going to know any
difference to them yeah but I want to
know I want to know statistics yeah I'm
giving more prominent Mal do you get it
because everyone's been surrounded by my
mouth if he was forced to be in a female
you know I am we live like okay so
management wise we're talking about
management no but I'm talking about
consensus I'm talking about centers and
getting a demographic of people I want
to know how the fact that men like men
are there like what you say make sixty
thousand women all the senses say that
actually working for women creates me
more problems I want to know what what
has men done to make women say actually
if I work for a woman I don't actually
like it as much men I'm at sixty
thousand sixty thousand men are
attracted to women so of course women
are going to have a better working
experience working for men
women are attracted to men
so and the sky is blue
it supports that says that women prefer
yeah it's equal it's equal but the only
difference is that women women don't
like working for women they like working
for men men say I don't care no I feel
like men have a certain approach like
we're saying women and men are very
different in the workplace and I feel
like their approaches are different so
maybe males tend to like interactive
women in a more like you know they
understand the nature of women hiring
people has actually like kind of put me
like understand like why there's more
uh men and Leadership positions and
positions of power because I found like
the the best paid jobs and the high like
jobs like women don't want to do because
it's they're stressful so like
so I'll give you an example so my
recruiting my recruiter like that's
probably one of the highest paid jobs I
have that's a really hard job to get
that many people in like what any 20 to
50 girls four days a week that's really
hard and stressful because if you don't
get me guests like the whole show fails
so it's it's paid well but it's also
high stress but I I had um my roommate
just I said you would make way more
money you can do this job she did it for
a week she said you can't pay me to do
this this sucks and when I when I I
brought the job to my team no one on my
team wanted to do it and it's like they
could make double what they're making at
their jobs that they do but it's hard
oh you showed us I've been I agree but
that may be a little bit of law of
averages yeah what do you mean law of
average of like obviously it would have
been a waste of time and money that's
why you wouldn't go on the route of law
on average but if you tried more and
more girls you would have stumbled
across one that could handle it you
didn't like the person you chose oh I'm
not saying that like no women can do it
no that's not what I'm saying
I would kill I used to do recruiting I
would kill oh my God I would I would
kill the recruiting but like I just
think in general women don't want to do
those jobs like across the board like
women don't want the super high stress
jobs
and even even like oil rigs right like
that that's a six-figure job you can do
right away how many of y'all want to go
work on an oil rig yeah yeah you
couldn't pay me to they could pay me
300K a year you would not catch me on an
oil rate that goes back to night of some
man's world a lot of things were started
from men doing a lot of yeah I'm saying
nope
I think women just don't want to do hard
jobs I feel like we just don't want to
do something that doesn't serve us well
I feel that for myself I don't mind
doing a job that can be a bit you know
intense but it needs to serve me well I
feel like some women that feel like
they've been served well so 100 so you
could work you could work on the nights
on a train engineering on train you know
guys on the orange and that yeah yeah
you can there's not nothing stopping you
from doing that job nothing from you
could make 100K doing that job yeah it
doesn't how can 100K not serve you well
not to say that 100K is not saving me
well but do I want to be bending and
straining my back long term for how many
years that's going to give me a long
term you know Health but men don't have
a choice right right give me
if we don't do that job you cannot catch
a train
no no no no no no no no no because this
what you're doing is another guy that
will but you won't do it so so but you
could but you won't do something no but
this is me but this is this is
so this is this is the point when I said
like met like women don't want to build
the world because like even no no no no
no I'm saying like you said but you're
picking stop stop saying this is what
I'm saying like in society like you were
saying it's cultural right and like like
because women didn't see like women in
positions of power it's all influenced
but even today when we have every
opportunity women still don't want to do
it they don't want to do the hardest
jobs which put your body on the line of
course like I said yeah that's that was
one of the things
I used to interview there was there was
a point there is a point where I
interviewed um top Executives
um I just decided I wanted more rich
friends and it's kind of funny you can
call them up yeah yeah I just thought it
was like my friend group two broke
and so what I did was I like to network
um this is when I was 22 I just called
them up and said I'm 22. I want to learn
and like I talked to like top Executives
at billion dollar companies and you
could just see the toll like because
they've been working 80 you know on
their face seriously they look so tired
they look so burned out because they've
been working 80 hours a week for 30 40
years who wants to do that you couldn't
pay me to work that much
just quickly say very like I think it's
also we need to acknowledge that it's
sort of like a generational trauma thing
because if you saw your dad working 80
hours and you're you know that your
granddad did that and then that's the
generation that you came from no trouble
my dad loves it he's still working
maybe not not generational trauma just a
generational pattern should we say but
when you see you know because we lead by
example as parents so we sort of are
conditioned whether it's negatively or
positively to sort of go into the same
sort of roles as our parents it's when
we break those patterns and go off and
do different things that that's like a
little bit strange no no it's just I
make observations and I just I like
again my dad has friends that are in
similar fields in him like do as well as
he does and I'm just saying women I
probably women because the women don't
see it exactly I agree with you on that
yeah because again they've seen their
generations of patterns with maybe
um you know the the home what was the
word Homemakers
um you know they've seen the Homemakers
if they've seen you know their their the
women in their family in certain roles
and then because they've been you know
again like learning from older these
people we've been we've had been able to
work since the 70s
actually it they say that it takes like
two decades for like a change to be
implemented in society like fully so I
do still think we are changing the
gender they started entering the
workforce at World War II sorry go ahead
go ahead no no I'm
I just think that it's going to take
more time if women want these big jobs
and they probably won't want the more
physical ones that they're not possible
you know able to do but I think it will
just take longer for women to have those
higher roles maybe so why is it why is
it that when countries where women have
more Choice the pay Gap increases it
doesn't decrease
so if you if you make a list of
countries so like let's say Saudi Arabia
women have less choice and we say in um
more what is it either it's eastern
Europe Eastern European no no not
Eastern European it's um there's one
country where it's like but okay let's
take the U.S there's a few more free
they're more free right so when you look
at countries that are more free the pay
Gap increases it doesn't decrease and
you get more women like you get more
women being nurses and more men being
doctors rather than decreasing why do
you think that is if if it's like a
generational thing subconsciously for me
I have I don't have kids but I really
feel that that's going to be the hardest
job on Earth
so I'm just like
maybe men do the rest because
um
Carrie what
uh do what no my titty uh
um so I'm happy to be on this side of
stuff I'm happy I'm I'm okay I can dip
my toe in over there you know I can
carry a little one
so I can carry on one thing for you I
can help but like
I I think subconsciously whether I'm
conditioned or not I just feel like
giving birth and being a mum that is for
life
I'm I don't know but I feel like that's
gonna be harder that's the job I'm as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible